maybe i wet your beak for the companions
if you can commit to my what you're
being i mean i mean if i'll commit if
you can wet my beak at your beak a
little bit yeah with that old drive
by that thing's dry right the bee's
cracking daddy doesn't want to have to
go away are we going
hurry up daddy doesn't want to have to
go away you know you wet my beak i want
your b come on
no we do it we do the fight companion
because i got to go on the road
otherwise i got i got daddy has to get
out of here he doesn't want to be in
yeah i know you know what i'm saying no
i'll cut you in i'll get you in on the
deal you're a big daddy now yeah daddy
big big daddy yeah i'm a big daddy you
got rinks over here
a little little something for you cake
is dry
i gotta come to you with hat in my hand
no
i made the offer all right now is it too
early to drink whiskey
you know what though it's early
because sometimes
we celebrate and sometimes we get back
to the old school fighters this is the
old school [ __ ] you know we miss
rappel we love chapelle i love chapelle
love him i love that guy also jim passed
away and chen passed away jim passed
away look cat and casey is running it we
got meatball here so this is the new
staff no it's very sim passed away yeah
but god bless jen cheers buddy god bless
everybody else it's good good to see you
good to be in here yep now
can i ask you a question before we get
in because i want to get into a lot of
stuff was that whistle yep whistling
andy from montana
isn't that nice i can drink whiskey i
used to not be able to drink whiskey now
i could drink it all day long all day
long all day long all day long
all day long all day long now
did you get anybody angry
at you what did you do when i wasn't
looking because i feel like you might
have done you might have said something
on below the belt or one of your shows
well you're little look a little you
look a little lost right now but um what
happened i'm asking well
i
i there's a journalist that got all
bunched up came after me
i didn't do anything i don't even know
him
i'm just walking the earth i'm walking
there i walk the earth that's my
favorite part he came up to you
and now i'm getting dude come after me
don't go after brian very nice
conversation with this was that nice
i've never said one bad thing about this
person what did i tell you what i tell
you now this journalist and you said
dude and i i told you guys this when i
when i uh talked about it earlier i'm
finally a kid there's a few things it's
like ellen in la when you come to l.a
you i can guarantee you two things you
can get a parking ticket you're gonna
hear ellen's an [ __ ] yeah when you
get an mma you're gonna hear it now take
it easy no hold on you're here two
things no don't go two let's not you're
gonna have two things yeah khabib's the
goat yeah
and the journalist is a complete
nightmare to work with okay i don't know
that's not me
i didn't start that you're already doing
it now i want to do that i didn't start
that but you're no you're being
mischievous what
journalists they need to tell the
stories they're the warriors no you're
doing you're doing some stuff now stop
[ __ ] with the machine machinery hold
on we've been fired remember now stop
being fired i told you not to do this
i'm not doing it
hold on
all i'm saying is this
i don't like i don't like
this stuff
i don't like we are a comedy podcast i'm
not interested in going bad on anybody
especially when i have a nice
conversation with this person i've never
seen anything about it you didn't though
that was fake it was seen as true
color it bums me out
i i don't can't help it he's the ellen
of mma why ellen of mma i have not
remember there's like the rumblings of
like ellen and cosby and all that [ __ ]
same thing here's the thing i don't know
okay listen i don't like having no
friends with anybody i have a thing with
with a couple things i don't like but
you don't like going back with us
but we don't even have a thing at all
but
i was thinking about this on the way in
here literally the only time i thought
about it slept great last night my only
thing is is
it just it hasn't worked out and so and
so you gotta point the finger because
you're not coming after me because i'm
doing bad you're not doing bad oh you're
doing pretty well oh daddy yeah oh let's
just keep doing better i know here's it
i just don't like being mischaracterized
and i don't like i don't like where
somebody says that that i or we said
something that i don't like that and i
also don't want to go bad on anybody
who's not here to defend themselves i
also don't have a beef with anybody i
actually don't i i you know me i just
don't so hey hey take it easy he's not
important enough to have a beef right i
mean but he has to do it so i get it i
get it dude it's been tough
and tough man hasn't worked out
you're back at square one all right all
right let's move on i just wanted to see
if you would and you're doing it right
now stop it what i do
dude you know i'm not talking you know
i'm a nice guy you're the first team
first team all nice guy you are how many
people do i help out
a lot a lot of people [ __ ] loads of [ __ ]
they don't know about that you have a
lot of friends yup tons of friends love
you yeah who love me here's my thing i'm
such a nice guy i was gonna uh
this tell me this is nice i'm in vegas
tonight friday and saturday i was like
he's never seen a show he doesn't like
my comedy you don't like my comedy come
see for yourself well i don't make tommy
for soy boys
so here's my thing i thought we're gonna
make an exception because they have a no
soy boy rule at most the clubs all right
and no i'm gonna stop
[Applause]
so i was like i'll i'll have him come to
vegas thursday friday and saturday and
then it hit me oh my god he can't come
to vegas
he's banned from vegas all right no no
no the journey no i mean i'm not saying
his name okay let's he's banned from the
did you know i'm just saying he's banned
no you're being mischievous bro no i'm
trying to give the guy tax to my sold
out
you're more you're being more that's not
nice i don't want you to be you know
what i asked the club i said hey can you
put this journalist down and they go
he's banned
and i said oh my god that's right
because he got all right all right let's
change the subject can we move on fire
can we move on can we move i have
nothing i didn't do anything you're
acting very innocent little me
you're not little old you right now you
know me yes you're being mischievous
here's here's my whole thing with if you
want to squash the beef whatever if he
has beef that's fine
i dare you
dare you come on the show
you won't talk like this in my face or
i'll fly to new york
dude come on
come on stop looking lost
you're looking lost and innocent right
now but i'm not even talking about
there's no threat here there's nothing
come on we talking about but you want to
talk about brian the kid callum the 52
year old 24.
too old to have beef i can't do it i
can't do it and i can't i can't get
anybody but he said if you saw in person
you'd run
i
now i'm very insecure with that stuff i
love that prince when i heard that i'm
like oh yeah i mean it's secure you
can't do that with me because i get
insecure so what happens is i'm so
inspiring i know it's right
because my biggest fear is i'm a coward
my biggest aspiration is to be a hero so
we know you're not a coward the young
guy so now so when that happens hey i
get all the younger i get all right
no stop
stop doing that i haven't i haven't said
anything
you're not so innocent right now so i
want to change the subject i want to
move on because we have work to do but
if you're in a room we have work to do
hey but if you're in a room with them
i gotta run i'm gonna run you're gonna
run i'm afraid you're afraid i'm afraid
right i don't want any trouble heard the
journalist has hands
dude and all i know how to do is sit in
the pocket that's all i know how to do
now a lot of people see you toy you
piece me up a little bit so they make
the mistake of thinking
that i'm illiterate when it comes to i'm
a betting man it's well documented i
like to make bets yeah
about my entire salary
if you guys went face-to-face dude look
at the 53 old man would wearing a tight
shirt so you see what i'm working with
it's a little unfair it's unfair you are
black today to look shredded and yeah
and you're right you're flaring your
neck i'm doing this a little bit because
you're with me by the way when i'm
wearing a black shirt i this is at 54 i
still haven't let it go it's amazing
that i don't do
for a guy who wants to be big so i can't
believe it
it's incredible that i've never done
steroids and the only reason i've done
is i'm afraid it's going to [ __ ] with my
game your dick
i just i like everything right now it's
all going but i do this i the way i'm
sitting right now i will i will do this
with my arms we all do you're flexing i
do this and sometimes i do this look i
do this to make myself look oh to make
the to make it pop i'm just talking and
i'm just trying to peacock right now
because you because if that journalist
sees you you just want to know what
you're working with i i do it i do it
regardless i do it all the time i just
want people to
think that i'm you've been fired from
their job some
listen i want you to change the subject
i want you to stop doing this
please i'm begging you please please i'm
back back where you started now i'm
trying to change that what i do is this
i
this girl said i thought it was you i
called my boyfriend and i was like i
think brian callum is sitting in front
of me but i didn't see any cauliflower
here so i figured he probably had a
drain oh and i love that so much i was
like i was like
i didn't say anything i was like i went
oh yeah it's me thanks babe you wish you
had cauliflower badly yeah five from new
zealand um the thing is is uh i'm glad
we're here
wrestled in college that's all yeah i
know we know we tussled yesterday and i
i picked you up like you know what i
picked you up like a baby you did pick
me up like a baby it was a little bit
disconcerting how was that mount
for those elbows
elbows involved well my [ __ ] elbows
kept hitting the ground so my elbow's
just a little tender oh yeah because
you're trying to like shrimp out and
stuff all that stuff um i feel like when
we were and i tried to get the video
from kyle when we were when we were
toe-to-toe don't you get the video yeah
but he he edited it when we were told to
make you look worse yeah when we were
toe to toe though and you were throwing
you were throwing your [ __ ] and i
was a little bit there in the face no no
because you were there what scared me is
that i threw that knee just to mess
around but you ducked down like oh my
god that's scary yeah thank god we
weren't drinking
that older [ __ ] his nose up when i was
at aka todd duffy who couldn't be the
biggest absolute nightmare nightmare
monster you should beat the shelter
did he really nightmare so big and
strong best guy in train room i've ever
seen he's and and really nightmare a
monster and he's and i'm and i'm i get
to
quote unquote move around with
todd duffy why would they have you move
around with todd duffy well because you
you're on a rotation so the actor is in
there because luke uh
threw me luke and todd's bar i'd love to
see that no we they were just you know
they touched spar they move around you
know todd never got taken down in
practice nobody took him down bobby
lashley couldn't shane couldn't i
couldn't he's such a freak dude freak
freak oh i think he there's something
he's gonna play football george is a
freak
freak good guy too great guys he said to
me he goes brian because i kept doing
this this you know i was ducking this
way like that where you guys doing so i
could
you see all these belts the the belt's
there that's because people hear you use
their knees yes we do mma you're gonna
you're gonna just because he i almost
did it with him he goes you're gonna
you're gonna put your head into
somebody's need like he's a smart guy
too he had some protective technological
problem though where it [ __ ] his
career up
like he had some uh autoimmune or
something there's something yeah but he
he's just gonna it was
that's [ __ ] sports a lot of things
this thing was different though because
if he was healthy like if he had full
like health yeah talking world champ i'm
telling you do that absolutely you told
me about that a long time ago dude he
knocked
tim hank out with a juju jab
bring up todd duffy for a second
he was such a freak
his his physicality was cat on the
computer
i mean look at him
look at him 63 245 and like shred city
just ridiculous
and just a good dude like a great like
he was my training partner for a very
time so so sweet you know just like just
literally trying to protect me right you
know you know i'm like all right bodied
up bodied up dude that's a viking that's
a viking that's a that's a that's brock
lesnar's uh younger brother smaller
brother
he's as big as he is more athletic
though you think oh dude
freak he could play dn he he he he's
like the athleticism of like a boso
uh or or like uh
one of those watt brothers i'm telling
you man guy's a complete freak i've seen
freaks yeah you have todd duffy for you
to say that oh freak yeah dude he wanted
me to corner him he took a fight in
japan i think was japan somewhere in
asia he took a fight against austria
over him on a weak notice and he's like
shop can you corner me against alastair
over room and i was like i'm not flying
in japan dude i gotta stay here and
train but they fought each other how'd
they do and he went this is this is
type so weak notice obviously you're not
made to win it's in [ __ ] japan
against over him and he he came out of
the gate so hard he was trying to knock
[ __ ] out he was like either i'm
getting knocked out or you're getting
knocked out and he just threw caution in
the wind and brushed alistar over him
okay probably not the best game plan
against out and also this is alistair
like
juice city alistair
yeah juicy
first team all juice yeah you're there
yeah he's all he's all breasted up
todd duffy great dude though yeah if
they bred human beings for food
he'd be
you'd be like that's good breast meat
right there
well the nazis like you come with us oh
yeah you he's with us he's the aryan no
they're gonna pay high bucks for him to
uh impregnate women yes he's he's
which
which was a thing in nazi germany yeah
they had like freedom babies or
something they called them her freedom
babies
you know what i was watching last night
before bed i was watching schindler's
list because there would be a more
depressing movie tough one
i love all things world war ii and like
nazis it is
the toughest well i did it was so
depressing i had to turn off i was like
what's gonna cheer me up so i watched uh
first 48. the first sketch i ever did in
my life the first sketch i was in
hollywood the first hollywood thing i
ever did
was i got this show called mad tv never
heard of it and they said you're playing
schindler and
schindler's lost
that stuff i couldn't do that today oh
well i couldn't do it then because
somebody oh he got nixed somebody said
to steven spielberg
they're doing [ __ ] lost and he said if
you do that i'm gonna shut you
and we did not air dude he made e.t i
found it to be very i remembered the guy
that created he's gonna let that fly i
remember i was just a new guy and i
thought it was super it was super uh in
bad taste and i said that i go are we
gonna because i had been a nazi germany
was my area focused as a history major
oh wow that's cool yeah so i was like i
don't think this is so cool but i was
new
you just did you they throw you in a
sketch i was like all right and most of
the people that were writing it were
jewish so i was like all right so yeah
you don't know you're just talent i'm
just doing what they told me it was
interesting but anyway schindler's
schindler's launch was my blonde wig
right there and shaved shave chest
there i am
look at rogan dude broken was he young
that's when i first met joe rogan you
guys bet on matt tv right yep that was
the first time i met him and we got
along did you know he's gonna be the
oprah for men at that time nobody knew
he was just but he was always so intense
joe was always ahead of he was like he
just would find his way through
some girl said to him one time you got
lucky because you're on tv
i figured my way through i'm a bulldog
he said he said that to her yeah he goes
i'm a bulldog and i earned it i figured
my way through and he did he would just
he was saying he was fortunate because
he's only doing stand up like four to
six years and they got a tv show yeah
but yeah he's radio but you have to
understand it's talent you have to
understand something about him when he
was that age let me tell you something
you want to talk about a dude who could
destroy rooms people no but you want to
talk about oh yeah you could no i know
who could destroy rooms when he was that
age people think like
i'm telling you dude at that age
he used to do things like to fight
tigers [ __ ] and stuff i'm telling you
first of all the other thing they don't
know about rogan is his his impressions
he's as good an impressionist as anybody
he's as good as joseph you just know
that no i didn't know that because he
you'll see you'll hear it a little bit
on the shows because he'll do like he'll
do uh bill clinton hoodoo trump oh dude
and i don't people like damn that's good
but it's like that's not working yeah
it's like he can do all this no no so so
i've actually never said this and that's
funny i always forget this there are a
couple things that people don't know
about joe one he can draw really well
he's an immigrant he's an artist he's
actually
an artist he's a high-level pool player
and he can do impressions he can do
impression if he puts his mind to it he
can do impressions as well as sasso
stupid that's crazy to say success was
the best ever but
if you said to joe you
and sasso and and um who's my boy i know
who else is really good impressions that
i tossed up there shane gillis what's
his name
yeah mike frankie later oh yeah if you
put if it was a competition and rogan
had some time
it'd be a very neck in that competition
you know who's um
gillis is a monster at that though is he
monster yeah monster well well
rogan rogan used to destroy rooms at
that age he used to [ __ ] i remember
seeing him at the comedy store one time
there was this big porn thing and
somebody got up and it was like the
dirty show that sam triple he got up in
a packed house and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this i see i don't know
if me and rogan be friends let's say we
both started when he was young and i was
young because we're both bulldogs i
don't know if it'd be like two siamese
fish around no you would have been fine
because you would have been cause back
then he was like so competitive maybe
you can beat the [ __ ] out of everybody
no but let's let's say i cut it
well but you could yeah all right no no
i'm just saying but no but he but he but
he's not scared of that
of confidence
like he's a black belt too no yes he is
scared of no no hold on
rogan i had conversations with roger one
time i said uh i said he was talking
about jiu jitsu and i said i said
i i think i tried to grab you or
something and i said
dude do you know like have you ever
tried to roll with him or something i go
do you know how strong i think it was
after i saw you with jake shields and
all those guys at the gym well i had to
defend when you were when you were just
beating up everybody defended you yeah
do the same thing to you
it was so crazy you beat up everybody
yeah
please sir sir please we're moving on i
moved on okay
okay
and and uh okay man i see you you're
you're you're mouthing things and i just
feel like you're
all right anyway
brian beat the [ __ ] but he but rogue
but rogan said
he goes i said because i wanted to make
sure rogan knew what would happen like i
was like el rosenzo and he goes like
this he goes
no i go you roll with him dude he's a
gorilla
he's a gorilla like he knows very well
yeah so i think that he would have known
that physically there was no way we're
similar in a lot of ways as far as
driving stuff so sometimes that can make
a weird like competitive yeah but even
now we kind of have a petition why it's
competition
like if one of you died you'd be like
i gotta take it over
yes it's it's uh
he's
but he's a monster quietly competitive
he was uh you know david luke is in
austin all the time he does kill tony
shout out to tony he just killed tony
does all the shows and they went to
dinner with rogan
and uh dave was talking about davey was
talking about me to rogan he's talking
about uh i think uh you know tony
wrestle in high school or whatever the
golden pony he's talking about wrestling
he's like i'd like to get my hands on
job and david was like have have you uh
have you seen him said that tony just
joking around okay okay and that's what
rogan said to david he's like have you
guys tried to rush his shop and dave's
like i would no i'm not that stupid he's
like i've seen him go against some guys
no anybody who's wrestled or anybody's
done jiu jitsu especially black belts
when they're my size they know that be
that's hilarious
i think the frustrating thing for a guy
my size who's a black belt in jiu jitsu
what's frustrating is all that training
kind of means nothing when it depends
there's one percentage out there i'm
telling you i know i know you don't
believe me i don't believe i don't but i
like what you're saying i'm telling you
crone gracie man i'm telling you we
rolled for 20 minutes it's amazing a war
he's a war and he submitted me at the
end of it in front of all his students
okay
it was ghee i'm telling a war dude cool
[ __ ] war cool that time i was a i
don't know three stripe brown belt
it's just
he's a one one one one percenter
i'm telling you dude you gotta believe
me on this don't but okay all right and
i really respect him i'm telling you we
did king of the hill and it came down to
me and him sure did he was getting ready
for metamorph so i was getting ready for
metamorph got you tonight he submitted
me armbar he would have snapped my arm
if i didn't tap
snap my arm dude cool you gotta watch
him train i'm freak i know he's a freak
i've seen him i've seen one
[Music]
ridiculously incredible
all right i appreciate you saying that
i really do appreciate you and i
appreciate the respect you give to the
legacy of jiu jitsu i do so that's all
i'm going to say that's fine
that's fine
now would i like to see rogan mark maron
roll yes
well what wait what
why why oh i don't know nah
that's a
look we're not
confrontational you hate confrontation i
just hate all of it i hate all of it you
know this is what i hate and this is the
internet in a nutshell
is if marin
the journalist any of those guys saw us
in person
you're not keeping the same energy and
i'm not talking about threats i'm not
there's no physical bullying there's i'm
not talking about any of that yeah i'm
saying you don't have the balls
to do any of that
i just
for me i wish that we would all and
there's not that we not go bad on each
other because unless you do it if you
have a beef somebody just confront them
if there's a legit have a talk if
there's a legit yeah you have to you
mean like call and text anything like
that
or or call or try that or or go to tried
that tried that to me
my generation
man it's it's i don't like that i'm like
my platform to go bad on somebody i
don't like it no and that's why you're
successful i just and also i don't i
don't have time i don't have time to
have a fight but b you got to realize
when and i'm not just talking about the
journalists in general but anybody mayor
and anybody you're not doing great if
that's your stance like if that's your
thing
if you're if and that was my random
bullet about like if that's your thing
you got maybe two weeks left of this
dude for any of you guys maybe two weeks
dude you might get some clicks out of
that then at the end like right what
else you got nothing
well i think something because you're
talking it's a life lesson the people
the people you're going after
you're not going after them because i
mean
top five most famous people in the world
probably well he's also an important
voice i think the most important i
really do so you're not going after him
because he's doing bad like does anybody
go after anybody doing bad yeah i mean
yeah
he can't even do a jesse smolette joke
in him it's like
it's like all right you're gonna keep
kicking the guys down it's over dude get
over it
yeah you know it's like you you know you
can go after carlos mencia yeah the way
i look at it is there's enough [ __ ] in
the world and life is enough of a
[ __ ]
wheel to push up a hill and i think that
if you are
i have enough trouble just dealing with
myself and trying to get ahead i got
problems and some challenges and it's
you know so for me i'm trying to write
so if i'm driving i'm i'm writing i'm
trying to come up with a really funny
half hour that we can put on youtube yep
that i'm gonna produce for you in the
market yeah exactly you know we've
talked about all this yes that's what
i'm thinking about i'm thinking about
that i'm thinking about raising my kids
the best way i can i'm thinking about
all that stuff
i don't have social media so i didn't
that's the other thing that has to hurt
i don't see any of it yeah i have to
have meatball or somebody'll be like hey
dude this and i go don't show me just
give me the gist of this i know what's
going on yeah that's it dude yeah yeah
i'm you know
the best thing you ever did is get off
social media yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
just ever because it's it's a it's just
it's too addictive it's too time
consuming it's also white noise i'm also
building a business yeah and it hasn't
that doesn't know that stuff helps i've
guys who do it it sucks that you can't
sell tickets oh yeah you do sell a lot
of tickets i forgot
about that man and that's the that's the
thing right now
we've come a long way and i'm so merch
either no that's what he said no
no we've come a long way and that and
and there's a lot now yeah what are you
gonna i mean what are you gonna do
and what are you gonna do there's just
you know off you're pissed now kind of
made your network picked up my 30 minute
special
i shoot in november in dallas
dude you seem upset about that i'm i'm
upset for them
you know what i'm saying it's like
what's this getting a [ __ ] stop dude
you're upset for them i'm upset all
right let's let's but again let's move
on dude i feel like you brought this up
no we have more stuff to talk about am i
going to is thick boy productions
produce counts 30 minutes hot [ __ ]
special yeah we are yeah we're going to
do all the marking around it yeah we are
i'm ready it's going to be the most
viewed special you've ever had you
guarantee it yeah yeah and let's let's
go i'm excited you can wet my beak
shoot in january you down for january
yeah i'd love to
we'll get the dates do you ever have
you're lined up in january
uh yeah i got some stuff we'll talk pick
a good one like a good city you know
yeah man i'd love to it'll be fun huh i
love it i'd love it i wonder if there's
rumor i'm doing austin even oh
the new cap cities yeah that's a good
idea sick right then we'll go on rogue
and talk about it
yuppy yuppie yuppie my boy here you know
casey's shooting mine shooting my
special casey peter i have my team doing
it maybe maybe they're shooting mine i
don't know
i'll figure it out let your beak dude
you know you're full time back on cal
best fight companion thick boy's gonna
[ __ ] produce it
right
we don't know dude
i'm asking questions all i'm doing i'm
i'm one man trying to get from point a
to point b the best way i know how do i
do i act and feel a lot younger than i
am sure yeah you act younger than i do
do i wake up with wood yeah yeah
could i keep you busy if we were doing
stand-up probably although you did check
my back kick yesterday you told me you
told me
i'm talking to you i turned and i kicked
and you you checked it that was
impressive oh yeah because you've you've
seen it before million times i was now
pat bear you still was at me
oh he did yeah and wonder boy they both
did that's gonna hurt your feelings oh
so that's why you saw my back kick
because i always thought my back it was
my oh and then oh dude i forgot i
sparred with tyrone spong the world
champion who also threw back kicks
with him yeah
that's a handsome guy what was the worst
work in the world i can't believe you
sparred oh yeah tyrone spun that's a
dutch kickboxing [ __ ] phenom he's a
freak
he lit all of he lit all of us up
starting handsome man handsome
[ __ ]
keep him away from body girl
keep him away from my girl
that's a that's that guy is
if i'm a cuck that's i'm i'm hiring that
guy yeah and and even if you're not
how's the house
how's cook work how's cooking work do we
know dude the thing is cuck is when you
get a guy like tyrants no i know but do
does the guy reach out to him now you
you had to spar with that [ __ ] dude
yeah i did at blackzilians and what
would you you just get in there with
like headgear and the way i saw it yeah
and you know i'm not the biggest kicker
in the world so
you just ate my legs up oh i just come
with my jab in right hand is that what
you do nightmare
so you had that you had to punch him and
he was kicking you the only few rounds
at black zone how big is he
six two maybe maybe six one six one
nightmare maybe six foot one and he can
he can generate a little do you see the
picture with all the belts in the world
yeah
that's a nightmare dude that guy's super
stunned then he did professional boxing
so when you would do would you help some
of the youtubers i hope some of the on
what tips i mean i get a [ __ ]
i could have jane john wayne par my
corner it's not gonna help against that
guy you know he's just giving you looks
it's like when that last girl i think
lauren murphy was fighting uh uh chef
jenko yeah she went back to the corner
and they're like she's just [ __ ] good
man there's nothing there's nothing we
don't have enough hours in the day
though we just no it's just trying to
knock yourself out
yeah it's just like you know good god i
go back tornado here keep your hands up
breathe yeah so so you've had some and
and and leona machida i think he's
thrown some background with leona for a
long long time so that's why you saw my
back kick oh and i sparred with anderson
silva
and anderson silva
and that's why you saw my backache it's
good back kick though it was a good back
kick but i felt but i caught i caught
shin got you in the chat are your shins
conditioned yeah they're dead they are
dead so when i scrape them like i'm
riding my bike stuff doesn't matter
can't feel it i didn't know that yeah so
you you got this it's like your botox on
your face i can't feel it
i've not had it but i want it doubt it
daddy i've not had you've had a lot of
surgeries no no botox no filler daddy
never had a little just i promise i
never have i never had had both and i've
had it offered
and they said and i was like what they
they're talking about the lines up top
right they can give you botox fillers
i've never done anything if it was
smooth up here it'd be weird right i
don't want it
i'd not get it but you just need it up
here maybe on the crows but i'm not
doing it but you really if you got off
for free
no you know what this is the first time
today i don't know if because earlier
i'm drinking it's the first time where
your eyes actually look better the
surgery two two years ago yeah with that
weight off daddy stopped drinking too
i have not daddy doesn't drink much so i
i get a little uh that could be you look
at look at the cleanest wood yeah you
can do a lot with fillers dude the only
problem is it doesn't you have to you
have to stay on it like girls that get
their lips done that's every six weeks
you gotta get your [ __ ] shots in your
lips dude and for what and i guess we
have like
you know
nothing if you have like the baby bird
like upper lip i get it but i'm waiting
for them to be able to edit genes so i
can just grow new cells you're hearing
me in the dirt but i'm not happy
but i'd like my that might be at my age
can we [ __ ] clone hair how long i
gotta wait for real well what's scary to
me and maybe they just don't give a [ __ ]
we get look at guys like lebron james
who has he's a billion you know he's the
first active billionaire and he's still
which was hey lebron this was dirty
wayne did this so giannis wins the nba
championship wins mvp
the day after he wins that the bronze
team blasts out first active billionaire
in the nba so that just takes all the
attention away from giannis it's like
you can't give him a little shine huh he
can give him a little shine
yeah also cool though
billionaire
still's got the same hair though shitty
here that's the point of this whole
story so he's shitty here billionaire
yeah you're not billing you're doing
well not billing
trump
a lot of money just the worst hair yeah
also i don't know if he just embraces it
yeah i don't think he i love when the
wind picks up and you can see the it's
like [ __ ] he's he's like [ __ ] what
you call it big daddy from uh
from uh
um what's that movie with uh woody
harrelson the bowler
oh yeah um kingpin
mayor bill murray's hearing that yes
that's trump and when the like the wind
picks up i want i want to hear like
titsy pass who's the team's player
like that like look that's trump's here
when it's like real windy and that is
correct sir
yeah it would be a funny human like
thick uh you know i wouldn't mind
casey's hair that's some good how old
are you casey 36 yeah he's young 36.
when i was 36 i had no gray and i had a
tight face and i look at pictures of
myself and i go i was a good looking
casey has no wrinkles nothing i was a
good looking kid dude you know daddy has
some grace big daddy over here he's
getting something you'll be great you've
just my dad hard you also live hard i'm
i don't live that hard well i'm in bed
by nine i think athletes though when are
you staying back in the day i think it
it see that i don't think obviously the
anxiety of fighting is a [ __ ]
disaster but that you know i was really
young then i think now more the stress
is just like coming up with new material
and then the planes and you're on the
road and then it never ends you're
getting back at two and running for
business having lots of employees kids
putting out fires
you know but you i also noticed that
athletes like you guys have thicker skin
in your face
like you just you just from the years of
maybe just scar tissue and all that
stuff maybe i don't know
i feel that yeah i get some greys though
the question is my girl digs it okay
because i used just for a men one time
nightmare he's just for men one time and
so it was like jet black i look like
sebastian's [ __ ] son yeah and she's
like don't do that she's like i like the
grace chicks dig the grays oh yeah salt
and pepper daddy yeah they love the
grapes you don't want to go all salt
though no you'll look good you're just
gonna be a giant man if you get gray
you'll be silver fox because you're not
losing your hair so now you got a shock
you got a shock of silver hair we call
that a shock a silver hair like aston
cooper like a man skunk does anderson
dies here is that naturally think
uh that's natural he's always he's
always been he's always been sick he
went he went what about when he was
younger he like steve martin went great
when he was very young you know steve
martin wears a wig
does he yep
really yep look at him oh wow
yeah he went gray super super he's aged
well yes good luck
good looking match jesus very good
looking man i actually have always liked
him
i've always people hate him and stuff
i've always thought he was um
he felt fair to me he felt at least
i don't watch cnn in years when he was
younger what got him to the dance i
thought was the way he handled a lot of
bad [ __ ] you know what makes me laugh is
when we were doing fight companion and
arguing with eddie and eddie's been
right on about 90 of things now when i
look back on all the [ __ ] he was talking
and he goes where do you get your news i
said i don't know cnn [ __ ] fox and he
was like you watched cnn i was like
what's wrong with eddie
that he was right well my my i get what
like you know because because the news
is essentially and now it's time for the
news and we're going to scare you it
could be one time
hold your attention by scaring you and
if we can't scare you we're going to
worry you which means we're going to
tell you what could go wrong because we
want to create
10 years we'll be living under water or
we won't you know and you're like can
you swim
right can you swim and it's like i hope
you can grow gills everybody because
we're going to be underwater
and you're like oh
[ __ ] that was a hard snake let's go that
was good
god bless you thanks dude
yeah that that whole getting covered
second time doesn't happen you know that
yeah i'm aware yeah come on you know me
dude okay
i'm excited rogan had on a cnn analyst
on the show
rogan had a cnn analyst on he comes out
today or tomorrow oh i'd like to watch
that
does he give him the business
i think so all right we'll see
those guys are funny because they don't
realize they're playing an away game
right you're walking to rogan's studio
of course he knows you're coming on he
has all his facts he's going to try to
he's going to he's going to get to the
truth he's he's like a mole have you
ever argued with rogan yes it is tough
i've had some arguments it is tough
it's tough and he'll change his mind
he's open-minded but but if if he if he
knows he's right and he has a stance
it's tough you know me i love to argue
yeah i i should have been a lawyer i
love to argue
that guy is tough to argue with yeah you
don't want a lot of those battles well
not when he's got all his facts in
that's the problem
you know
he dissolves factors the biggest thing
is americans are
they're being told one thing regardless
of where they get their information and
they're seeing something else they're
every day their day to day the distrust
is not saying this is not what i'm
seeing i'm not seeing racism everywhere
i'm just trying to get food on the table
you know it's i'm not seeing
i'm not seeing that that that
that trans people are that numerous
there's a lot they're trying to pull
chappelle's special from netflix
is that in your current adventure cat
you're kidding i mean they're never
going to
i love it
critical critics call it a canceled dave
special ridiculous good luck with that
there's a very very small but you know
the medical guys know trans people that
are just emailing netflix but you
realize this is what dave wants right
like this just brings back may not even
be trans people it may be it may be just
people can't it might be trolls it might
be
russian chinese trolls just trying to
create dissension that's what i think
i really well this lady says scroll up
kat she says i love so many there's so
many chords in my way anyways i left so
many of the people i've worked with at
netflix brilliant people and executives
have been collaborative
fought for important art but i've been
thrown against the wall because i'm not
a real woman i've had beer bottles
thrown at me so netflix i'm done
oh
all right that's fine
be done because there well because i'm
going to keep watching netflix i've
never heard of her and netflix
chappelle's brand has be become
synonymous with ricky and trans people
and other marginalized communities can't
tell jokes now huh so now what you
saying stand up special is taken for
word and those are your strong words all
i know is oh you can't make people i i
pray that netflix doesn't guarantee that
i bet you they don't do a thing no they
won't do anything
i mean netflix for me they pulled the
closer from its platform and directly
apologize to the transgender community
huh nah
because what does that mean the
transgender community don't act like the
transgender community one voice or one
group that's ridiculous
[Music]
i mean you know
yeah this but you got to realize
chappelle's so calculating so smart you
don't think he knows this was going to
trigger some people
yeah i think if you do a special whether
it's 30 or an hour and some people
aren't triggered you just didn't do your
job
and stand up especially in today's
society
like if you just if you if you just walk
the middle line nobody's gonna watch
your special look at this pathetic thing
you just try to make everybody happy
yeah it's just not nobody's gonna pay
attention again these are people who
don't do anything sir no these are
people that don't do anything and
they're and i love when they talk for
the they speak for the quote-unquote
transgender community there's not a
transgender community there's not a no
no no there's not a white community
there are people in that group who
happen to be transgender that or
identify as that yeah but there are a
lot of people who are transgender who
don't [ __ ] who are like what i'm just
trying to live my life because i feel
different and i'm trying to do something
about it and i'm trying
a lot of them probably like i don't give
a [ __ ] what dave chappelle said well
it's like when people think he's a comic
yeah like like when people say the black
vote or they say black people what do
you mean
black people are all over the map with
their opinions and philosophies and
and and
where they stand politically just like
white people are what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
it's the most annoying thing
anyway
it's interesting but i can't wait to
watch the closer now all right yeah but
that's why he's so calculated dude yeah
well now i'm gonna watch the closure but
in 2021 and i got this question i was
doing press in denver like did do you
find it hard to be a comic now with in
2021 staying away from subjects i'm like
no the way you fight back is
talking about those subjects and having
smart witty material on those subjects
you don't shy away from it because once
once comics start
you know
censoring themselves then you're in big
by the way you can also tell that you've
hit you're doing something right because
if because when people freak out a lot
of times it might be because
there's some truth to it yeah because
there's some truth to it and so what
happens is it's very threatening like
journalists because the truth
gets out there you know what else you
got countless
yeah
so bob uh aaron drops a huge [ __ ] her to
the host of the fury wild i like this
lady too for asking the fighters to face
off
so yeah play that one there i think it
it's queued up right where it should be
at
so they're just yelling at each other
she's she has a tough job
she's in the middle of these two
monsters
so i think
i think fury six six do you want to
watch six seven every bit of it
she's in the middle of it yeah and so
they're arguing she goes can we get a
face off and bob aaron you know who put
the thing together goes [ __ ] off
he does that click on yeah
from the uk
and
she and
she's slanting all the press conference
to wilder like i don't give a damn but
it's obvious that that's what she was
doing
and then
she knew that the understanding was no
facebook
tom
brown
argued with fox no facebook
we said no facebook and what does she
say
now we're going to do a facebook [ __ ]
her and [ __ ] them there was no face off
and we saved the fight that's an old man
who doesn't [ __ ] around he does bob
aaron does not give a [ __ ] he's at least
90. how far how old is bob aaron he's
been in the game for how long do you
think dana hates bob aaron or the
journalist more
89 that's a good question
he's 89. you can't hate an 89 year old
you got to just be like you're in
business forever 89 89 i didn't give a
[ __ ] if you tell me he's not more
coherent than [ __ ] biden oh dude 89
he he doesn't speak better than biden i
know when they're both speaking still
doing it still doing it at 89 if you
still give a [ __ ] that much like he's
still angry that that that's what keeps
him alive he's passionate yeah and she's
great too
my father's that way my father you're
dead smart speaks well he is and he's 81
and he's still kind of outraged at
things he doesn't get he's wet he has a
gut he's got a gut on him and doesn't
care my myself you know my dad beat up
your dad yeah 100 but my sister said my
sister was so mad at him because he's
eating so much but she goes you know
what keeps him alive his life force and
his opinion yeah if his heart could it
would jump out of his body and slap him
right in the [ __ ] face his heart's
sick of this [ __ ] his heart would be
like hey get gay
but you can't so
sometimes you're life force sometimes
you're out i'm just an old school
promoter look at him with don king
oh yeah dude criticized he's i you know
like all promoters he's got
has there been a promoter doesn't just
reap all the hate yeah there's never
been a promoter um um who's the guy uh
black guy um who who manages uh don king
no um
black guy i hate him uh hey hey hey
heyman
al haymon oh dude he seems to be a
little bit more he gets it too but yeah
he tends to be less criticized by
fighters i think i i don't know he seems
to be more
in their corner if it were as it were i
don't know
yeah he's a mayweather guy but the thing
with mayweather that made him different
than other fighters is
dude i've been in the room with him i've
seen how he operates you're talking
about a [ __ ] sniper oh um mayweather
oh dude genius you know just to be in
the room during the
his q a he had to prove everybody i
believe that so he he couldn't be in the
room unless he single-handedly was like
yep
wow
well he's he knows how to play the game
i told you when when he when he was the
best yeah they taught him man yeah i
told you when i was working the logan
paul floyd mayweather fight i went to
the restaurant and his whole team all
all of them all of them were coming out
and he goes i know you you're the white
boy works too much
that's me dude oh is that right yeah
that's me dude wow so you're all over
man i'm like yeah i'm exhausted
that's pretty cool yeah yeah he's um
dude i'm i'm talking you i've never seen
an athlete or
even an entertainer
down to a the details you're texting me
i'm sure kevin hart technically from all
that all the stuff there's the cactus oh
he's just smart
sober thoughtful i know people are like
oh he can't read who gives a [ __ ] you
know what i'm talking about dude i'm
talking he knew the camera shots the
angles it was well he might be very like
ditch that camera bring camera a over in
the roaming camera here like holy [ __ ]
dude
yeah
he's a he's a savvy dude i i think part
of what makes him a great boxer though
not is not just obviously his schooling
but i think some dudes you could speak
to this more i think some dudes just can
see shots better they can just see this
yeah
he's been doing in diapers yeah that's
my argument with fury like you know he's
been in diapers so it's like he's seen
everything any style you bring they've
seen in the in when they're in amateurs
or golden gloves or olympics like
they've seen it all every look you get
every like look there's like an mma
because guys don't have as much
experience even the champs sometimes
they fight a guy where it's like they've
never seen that style it gives them
problems
so it's like you know wonder boy
everyone's like yeah he's a tough
matchup for everybody
facts yeah you're right but in boxing
there's no style that these guys at this
level have not seen that's right they've
seen it all dude that's right you know
what i'm saying that's exactly right
i think that's really interesting about
that so depending on also like when you
watch folk wrestlers deal with these
dagestanis who are doing [ __ ] and greco
it's a chain wrestling they haven't seen
yeah it's almost like i've been speaking
french and you're coming in now you're
coming at me with chinese yeah i don't
what the [ __ ] is this yep and then
you're trying to download it compete and
there's not enough hours in the day and
it's the language they're fluent in you
can't you the transitions it's like
and people would study his tape and
they'd be like oh this is what he does
in his cage and then when you go against
them you'll defend that and they have
seven other ways to take you down that
you had no clue i know and because he's
been since he's in diapers he's been
running up the mountain [ __ ] leg
locking goats you know what i'm saying
it's like i know you see all that stuff
that's my i know you you're you're a
sand hating guy and you should be
because that's your team that's
christian allen you're seeing me being
biased because you're a warrior and i've
known him since he's 15. take all that
out of the window i'm telling you dude
stylistically it's a tough fight for
peter 100 i just think that peter i bet
peter diamond say the same thing yep i
just see things with peter young like
forget those [ __ ] trips which i've
actually never seen in mma but his
abilities hands his ability those little
details that russian boxing those little
details you don't have forward pressure
forward pressure's standing there and
he's stepping back i'm telling you you
know that
that's going to be a problem for him
it's going to be a problem he's going to
get knocked out
yeah
yep really telling you dude
really mm-hmm that but alex jermaine
sterling couldn't do it though
different you just talking about a
different animal
this is what the savage corey is so when
i was watching him spar because he's
still far out was that fight november
fight november i think
is it november december
yeah
yeah i believe it's november november
6th sometimes
we're doing a cowbest fight campaign
so the they spar like 10 rounds and
mostly guys in the was that that's
october 30th oh [ __ ] that's soon
so he's in camp right now
and
i said to his uh his coach um christian
allen i'm like dude he looks exhausted
he's like this is what corey does when
he's not in like he'll do a strict
training camp like six weeks out four
weeks out but right now
he likes he he wants to exhaust the
point where the worst guy in the room
[ __ ] him up puts him in bad positions
yeah he was watching i'm like dude you
probably get him out he looks [ __ ] i
mean just barely making it he's like
this is 10th round oh my god this is his
first day back smart oh my god i'm like
he's just 10 rounds he goes yeah he
likes to go to a mental place where they
can't break him i'm like yeah what a
[ __ ] sad he's been training with
christian allen i think since he was 16
15 15 years old he came in the gym at
15. i remember
and i remember seeing him he was
fighting at 45 at the time
and he walked by me and he's he's
roughly my size he's not that much
smaller yeah tall great guy great guy
yeah and i thought to myself this kid is
fighting now at 35 that's big has all
the talent and what's interesting is
christian and him train this kid who's
young he's like 18 now so he's a mix
he's a hybrid mix of corey and christian
and he's just coming up the ranks really
savage monsters
you see these young kids i'm like oh
that's so cool man it's
well i was thinking about canelo and
people like well he trained so hard well
he trained so hard because there are
people right at his door like the charlo
brothers like all these people that are
just
dying head hunting looking for him
you can't relax when you're a fighter
you cannot
not canelo's the thing about canelo is
this is what's always fast and i'll see
connor made all the money in the world
and now he's kind of half in half out
does his antics or whatever still a
great one run one of the greatest never
do it but you look at a guy like floyd
right or you look at a guy like canelo
and you look at guys like anthony joshua
anthony joshua has all the money in the
world like you can't get any more money
yeah i guess you could be like a bezos
type
he can't spend his money a lifetime his
kids can't spend their kids can't spend
it he's all set you can tell he's kind
of checked out they look at canelo who
probably has more money more famous i
know probably the biggest name in boxing
i know and trains like a goddamn band
broke trains like he's broke he's in san
diego
has it has a team of fighters that live
with them there he has a whole house for
them he trains them every day
that's another guy though came up in a
family of fighters what you got 27
brothers every one of them fighters and
he was guadalajara dude
born and raised
from something and and redhead
so he was basically a white guy i think
like bullying his family yeah well of
course because he's his redhead no
you're not even white you're just you
smolder in the sun
so i think that he i think his family
was originally from where like ireland
or something no
guadalajara right there's no irish in
them
well ethnically i think he's actually uh
he's actually
his ancestry is you think yes okay he's
so fierce yes yes yes he's not
yeah and he really explained that he was
born of the outskirts of guadalajara
spanish family virginia los reyes
canelo's spanish and the mexican word
for cinnamon yeah canelo means no i have
average heritage
um yeah click on that cat does canelo
have to see that
canelo has revealed there might have
been some irish grandfather somewhere
there in my past
his full name is santo saul alvarez
yeah mexican spelling according to one
hashtag the name bragging is mixed
stands for old irish name barrion yeah
he's so fierce skin and redhead oh yeah
yeah you're right you'd have to be irish
yeah if he did his genome i think you'd
you'd see something dude irish mexican
yeah no [ __ ] it's gonna be the best of
all it's a great combo the best combo
yeah dude i always forget my kids are
mexican yeah
all the time
yeah your kids are mexican it's a good
combo mexican i dropped i dropped off
school this morning he's crying because
that you don't have to leave for two
days and he's crying i'm like dude don't
cry in front of the other kids and then
spanish teacher i know
i start crying and uh his spanish
teacher goes man tigers really good
spanish i'm like he's mexican yeah well
because she's like he is like yes he's
100 mexicans like his mom his mom's born
and raised that makes him 100 and all
she does speak mexican to him she's like
that makes a lot of sense i'm like do
you have any white in you at all i know
yeah i'm just curious because between
you and canelo
i mean canelo dude if you were an alien
from a planet right and yeah right here
on his own they're showing you irish
people mexicans black people white
people and you showed canon like hey
what is c the aliens like
irish white super irish like from the
north of ireland is he's not black irish
my dad's irish and he's dark like you
this kid is from
he was from scandinavia yeah my darkness
i have a splash of the talent in me 18
no big deal that's it 18
it's 50 english
i know
and jay and my mom my dad's a little
dark your dad's
native american my dad's a full-blown
apache he truly is
all six four of us my dad was an action
apocalypto
and and did a good job in it yeah good
job did a very good job in it yeah and
and it was that's a great movie by the
way
one of the most underrated movies no one
spoke about it written directed by mel
gibson it is
it is one of the best movies ever and i
think it's actually in the old school
aztec language that's that's what i was
gonna bring up how the [ __ ] did they
learn that language it's a style are
there really people out there no [ __ ]
aztec language like how would they pick
the linguist how long do you have to
learn that
when you get the script like you know
you're speaking [ __ ] straight up he
wrote it aztec i think it's a i think
it's a masterpiece oh my god it's so
[ __ ] but it came out afterwards
after he was like
you seen it oh dude you missed watch it
tonight get some whiskey watch dude it's
fant it's so savage it's so savage yeah
i'd say schindler's list is even more
savage yeah this is schindler's list my
girl she was asleep and i'd bump her
wake up can you believe they did this
can you [ __ ] believe somebody would
do this yeah how insane is this like
when that kid you know the guy who's a
great actor he's in the red dragon you
know what i'm talking about um using
that move with j-lo but uh he's like the
main bad nazi runs the concentration
camp and that kid goes hey i was trying
to get the the dirt off the yeah off the
tub and i can't get it off and he won't
look at him he can tell he's scared yeah
and he goes you're free his name is rafe
that's right he goes you're free to go
go ahead and the kid just walking and
then he's like you're free to go and you
can tell he's like struggling with
letting this kid going are you free to
go
you're free to go and he's staring in
the mid in the mirror and then he gets
out his [ __ ] gun and pop she's
getting the [ __ ] head yeah he was uh
the problem with me with keith oscar for
that bro yeah he should yeah it was
insane when he's talking about the jews
he's like they're like a virus you know
it's just
it's mind-blowing that that happened in
our [ __ ] world it's
nuts to me dude that's right it's
absolutely [ __ ] mind-blowing right
and it all
or how about that how about oh there's
that piece of [ __ ] the real one that
could happen again set of ears on him
yeah it could happen again no that guy's
the survivor oh okay that's cool
he's a good guy to me complete [ __ ] i
thought that was the original yeah
i mean he played such an amazing it was
nice
how about that girl who's like is taker
and he's like attracted to her and he's
like this would never work though
because you know you're not even human
you're not a human and then kills her i
know he's like i want to grow old with
her but i can't you know and then kills
her and when he's going to kill he he's
the most the sickest thing is this woman
is in a concentration camp and he says
uh
and he goes one of you is a very lucky
that's where he kills her and he goes
don't come too close to me i have a cold
i don't want to give you my cold
meanwhile this is a concentration camp
it was so dude have you seen jojo rabbit
yeah
yeah one of the most original movies
i've ever made
and when when it when it was when it
first came out the trailer i was like it
was like step slap stick calm makes me
stupid yeah and then we were in san
antonio and it came on jay's like oh i
love this movie i'm like isn't it stupid
he's like you never seen jojo rap i'm
like no
dude yeah where he's like so unique oh
my god it's good and it's also not like
it's just
a child man besides from a child reminds
me of tigers dude well life is beautiful
is another one about have you seen life
as beautiful another one you won an
oscar oh no oh it's it's good
it's astonishing it and it's important
to understand what's such a good journey
ray finds i mean
well that's that's that's he's top ten
yeah he's top ten ray finally yeah top
10 100 yeah you don't get better no you
don't get better you're talking about a
guy who comes from the from the
from the one side england he says
he was doing shakespeare these guys cut
their teeth on the heart of the real
[ __ ] material so when when they do
monologues the reason that steven
spielberg saw him steven spielberg's tom
in a play oh wow yeah it's like it's
like mark rylance he saw him in a play
so these guys when they go to broadway
when they go to the west side of london
they see these productions they go oh
this guy's playing hamlet
and crushing it i'm going to be
memorizing the whole script and
everything but i mean also like bringing
spielberg uh schindler's list yes he did
jesus christ it's one of the great
movies and it's one of the hardest
movies to sit there you remember it came
out for christmas yeah it's an important
remember my dad was like we're going to
see schindler's list i was like i'm
going to my mom's opening gifts yeah and
then he was like all sad what's that the
reason it's important is to know
what happened
it happened and it was no it's history
it was a legal revolution it's
mind-blowing that the entire country
stood by and watched it's
it's not dude yeah it's nuts yes and the
history they teach us right in american
schools like america came and saved the
day dude we came in in the fifth round
we came in the fifth round it was the
russians
it was the russians that fought this
right and so many russians died more
russians died than anybody else i love
that you know oh yeah dude
oh yeah do you know how you remember how
we used to talk about this and i was an
idiot but you weren't an idiot you just
didn't i don't know but i imagine i
[ __ ] love that you are reading you're
a big influence in that dude
remember we sat down and all your smart
friends they were talking i'm like i
can't add to this conversation and
remember we got out of that dinner and
you're you're quiet like johnny start
reading dude and i was like can you give
me some books remember that and then
remember also i mean i met with a speech
coach which kind of helping but um
remember uh we would go over my my
vocabulary with you yeah
you'd like because i used to say i
haven't eaten yet yeah i haven't eaten i
haven't eaten i haven't eaten yet like
dude you gotta quit saying that yeah and
i'd say anyways like there's no s on
anyway yeah well there are all kinds of
things like that but you just that was
not what you studied hey you don't see
colorado hey
yeah
someone's paying for this but to your
credit yeah i remember i remember that
dinner when you were quiet and we were
talking about history a light bulb went
off with that and you went i have a big
deficit and i have to but the fact that
you just said that about russia is
astonishing to me it's it's amazing
you've been reading oh yeah and what's
interesting is so when the american
troops came in and we like took over
germany america you know we're good
people we didn't [ __ ] around and rape
women and kill children we do that
russia
because what germany did to the russians
where they'd you know take over the
cities and rape and kill the children
well russia went eye for an eye y'all so
they didn't play nice like we did they
did what they did to them because they
because more of them died than anybody
so they dude they were savages horrible
it's
horrifying to the it's the number of
dead is too much to bear cap bring up
how many uh russians down world here's
the fundamental difference between this
will blow your mind for those of you
world war one world war one and world
war ii
was the first time when you could
mechanize mass slaughter machine guns
and poison gas and artillery
and
perhaps most importantly aerial
bombardments you could bomb with
incendiary bombs you could just drop
them on cities so the death toll was
astronomical it would never used to be
that way it was when when carnage soviet
union 24 million
overall they think uh a hundred million
people died between world war one and
world war ii which was the which was the
the european civil war you know it
lasted that long oh [ __ ] dude trench
warfare
poison gas that's crazy when you look at
the history of winston churchill who
they would be like hey man this hitler
had kind of a problem yeah it's not big
deal like i'm telling this guy he's
really rallying the troops dude that's
pretty
charismatic and
i'm giving you something neville
chamberlain
said to hitler go ahead and invade the
sudetenland uh in in munich that was the
great that was the great betrayal that's
when the nazis were like oh look
nobody's going to get in our way we can
just expand
and it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy so
you know hitler wanted to get into this
art school
if that teacher would have just let him
in the art school well same with like
charles manson all he wanted was a
[ __ ] rap he didn't get into the
vienna school the arts i believe because
you know why he couldn't draw a human
figure yeah it's like he could only draw
a [ __ ] [ __ ] control yeah but not
humans his buildings though he did not
lit as [ __ ] he hit his back dude what if
he came my house out of hitler painting
is that weird
well they probably was playing charles
manson his song
yeah the beach boys [ __ ] played some
of his songs [ __ ]
and it's so it's same if hitler would
have just got that
scholarship to draw i don't think we're
here didn't know how to draw the express
but then also if charles manson would
have just got that record deal i know
i know just how little things could
change the world you wonder in a way a
guy that who could speak that
charismatically and and came along at a
time when germany was humiliated after
world war one and the depression and
[ __ ] uh it's important to study these
things so you can see the when they
start to happen again hey hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa you know we know this is
that's the thing we know how this ends
and it starts so it starts
rogan had a really cool
he posted something on his instagram
that i thought was so [ __ ] good um
did everybody freak out about it no it
was um he posted this incredible thing
it was it was and i'll i think it's
worth
reading is it a negative cove it does
yeah yeah
hold on i'll read it cat's bringing it
up right now
oh good there it is
yeah listen to this
it's interesting shoot his picture for
the td gardens hilarious of all the
tyrannies the tyranny sincerely
exercised for the good of its victims
maybe the most oppressive it would be it
would be better to live under robber
barons than under omnipotent moral busy
bodies that's a word yeah omnipotent
means everywhere you're everywhere
you're kind of like omnipotent the
robber baron's cruelty may sometimes
sleep his cupidity may at some point be
satiated maybe he may have enough but
those who torment us for our own good
will torment us without end for they do
so with the approval of their own
conscience
so true who said that i don't know but
it's so true man it's when you when you
believe that you're doing good
and it's for our own good you're never
going to stop and that's that's that's
where you have to be [ __ ] careful of
government oversight
it's we saw the mandates california knew
some pests
you have to be vaccinated go into any
restaurant any any indoor facility now
yeah and guess how you do you have to
have a vaccine passport
so we are a car
card
that's a vaccine passport yeah that's
all it is you have to show proof on your
phone ladies and gentlemen and you have
to scan it don't point your finger now
when you scan it they got a record of
you being there yep so they're tracking
you you know let's do it china
i know yeah
so
so how what happened to what happened to
the fact that the newsome only has uh
what like eight months
left i think you only have eight months
left we are
they canada just voted in trudeau for a
second term you know it's like i don't
know man that's canada i'm not worried
about them but a new some only has i
think eight more months
i think you only have eight more months
i thought he has more than that i don't
think so dude because that's why people
were saying with the recall they're like
well
i mean even if we recall there's only
eight more months
sure yeah he doesn't have long
so the 46 recall came to a parent
children
this is an older article but scroll down
maybe there's info on there
fewer than 15 months as of okay
september all right
so we got uh october november december
january february
so he has like another year
about yeah it's gonna be tough
god it's a piece of [ __ ]
well just a guy who thinks he knows
better than you do and he believes in
government oversight to the degree where
you have to show proof of your vac your
coveted vaccine not your other vaccines
but that and
that's the question
what's this so jake paul recently found
a photo of tommy fury where he was at
the front desk of spirit airlines and he
decided to make fun of him saying this
is what happens when you turn down a one
million dollar fight
oh that's [ __ ] up
i think
this is the tick tock you posted i think
jake paul beats him by the way
bad i think he knocks him out yeah
see tommy for his last fight oh here we
go so this is a photo
i mean is that me
yeah just look like you from afar yeah
it does and then you get closer like
he's a lot leaner um that's funny he is
a dime piece got spared airline that
stuff but sometimes you never know
sometimes
you're flying it's the only option yeah
i have to fly at one time yeah but i'll
it is the greyhound of the skies it is a
nightmare i say can i get a water like
[ __ ] like you have a seatbelt i
remember he when the guy goes i'm not
flying to sarah anymore because you guys
charged me for a bag and i remember this
that flight of time goes like this he
was a guy he's like a gay guy he goes
like this he goes he goes okay
okay just like that
there's nothing hey there's nothing
better when airlines when people argue
with the airlines because i mean there's
only so many flights you can take so
they're they're like you cool dude
that's cool whatever you want to do
this is what happened on a one million
payday jesus christ
but sometimes it's like the only option
you can get you know like i think we're
in cleveland and my flight got cancelled
i need a direct flight back sunday
morning and my brother's like i have bad
news dude spirit's the only one that
flies direct to burbank like then spirit
is bubba spirit and the three of us flew
back on spirit and god damn yeah yeah
it is tough you think jake paul beats
thomas yeah knocked him out yeah yep
yeah tommy fury is very new to boxing
very new very nice yep you see his last
fight like [ __ ] dude i think he was only
like six rounds
jake knocks him out yeah he's got he's
got great breasts and
he turned down the fight there's a
reason his his team knows i may be the
end of his boxing career if he lost to
jake paul yeah yeah oh his team turned
it down yeah yeah yeah they know what's
up
yeah jake knocks him out unfortunately
jen how's your doctor appointment go i
told everybody you died earlier yeah and
now you're back how you doing buddy i'm
doing all right i got to go back though
okay i'll go back just did more blood
test this stupid [ __ ] but they didn't
did i just test they want every time i
see someone i get an x-ray and blood
tests blood tests blood tests it's all
the same [ __ ]
you can't recommend it they can be like
hey can i just get a [ __ ] mri
no
here's what you do you spend two
thousand dollars on an mri is it that i
thought it was way more no
spend two thousand dollars on a goddamn
mri yeah
call it call a clinic right now and go
spend the two grand
chin's in a bad spot
chin's [ __ ]
this blood test [ __ ] oh they're just
taking them for a run [ __ ]
go get a [ __ ] emerald you're gonna do
them like yeah dude same [ __ ] i'm like
thank you still in pain
like come on back and then we're dealing
with swords i know it's quick a couple
more hoops and then i'll get the mri no
no
go get the mri and then what do i do
with it just show
huh look at it good point what do you do
give it to a guy who knows i got a guy i
have to go through the system there's
just there's still there's a guy named
dr moser kapilmoza is
the best in the business
but let's say he takes a look at it and
then he's like all right you got some
bad nerve issues okay gospel is gonna be
like okay well we didn't do it well at
least you'll know what you're doing no
not if he runs out of the hospital
because he he works out of a hospital
i'm sure has no he doesn't he works
right here he has a clinic but he has a
clinic but then also he can recommend
you and be like this is my guy at this
hospital cedars road he also knows which
guys you shouldn't go to yeah okay
because because there's a it's a whole
racket dude it's all good i'll fix it up
[ __ ] there's a guy out there whose name
i will uh but i had he was a kabul
mozart this guy puts he gets kickbacks
he puts screws in your body okay because
he gets kickbacks from that company yeah
i'll do that's why they push pills and
all that i'm not conspiracy it's just
the business man yeah yeah and hospitals
pay attention
i'll make it through
but pissed off
pay for the mri yeah we'll figure out
how to help you with that
chin is pissed off dude
look at him i'm good
cat's been holding the fourth down doing
a good job here let me take a look at it
give me a try over here and take your
pants off i want to see what's going on
no because a lot of your neck problems
can be in your
eye and your your hip are we just going
to pretend cat didn't get in a fight
with a cougar
what happened to your jeans cat she's
all kind of uh another one for your
booty i saw the booty like the oh yeah
it has uh like these tear marks
everywhere i'm a hoarder i've had these
pants since high school i just don't get
rid of anything cool though thanks if i
have jeans that are fit dude i will rock
like those i can't wear them anymore
because the crotch busted out so many
times i took it to my lady who deals it
the tailor she's like there's nothing we
can do with these dudes they're too thin
they're going to keep ripping that had
to throw them away yeah i've had them
for
seven years yeah favorite [ __ ] jeans
sometimes you gotta throw now you like
this company kato they're based off la
but they make japanese denim jeans these
are kato favorite [ __ ] jeans yeah
japanese denim yeah my favorite but
these are they have a four-way see any
little elastic in the legs yeah so that
this cato company they're called pen
slims and they have like an elastic in
them but they're also the quality of
japanese
favorite jeans by far yeah you need a
little and they're based off of la so
you order them if you're in l.a but you
order them that day you give them the
next morning like they're the best have
you weighed yourself no i don't
underwear myself definitely over 270. oh
man no you just looked very big
yesterday when i was fighting you
all right you looked down you think i'm
over 270. you've i've never seen you
bigger just this
muscle-wise gotcha they're talking about
my no no i don't think you're fat you're
just big
i'm trying to slim down
special day i like those gator things
you don't have to it's a dumb thing to
do yeah you should just be big as [ __ ]
and stronger than everybody all right
you picked me up in a weird way
yesterday it was very weird to be picked
up that way yeah
yeah those are my favorite right
there a little little loop can't go the
other ones they had there
those are fire with the stripes those
daddy the houndstooth
they have a 38 in those
nope
god damn it
the chino pants dent beige houndstooth
come on cato that's the only thing about
this site they don't make a ton because
they're based out of la small shop
do it all by hand
i need those houndstooth come on kid
i'll send the hands tooth
wow
you would like those b probably i got a
lot of jeans
i go i can't get enough jeans i know
dude denim jackets jeans i'm not mad at
the boots they got some cool shoes there
that's not what they sell though you
know no how about those boots right
there no no you could pull those off
though no you could do it but they don't
sell them you know yeah they're a gene
company i might have to start wearing
those guys you can't like those boots
those guys are those boots right there i
like those we don't know dude this is a
gene company i keep saying i like them
all right what else you got cat okay
shout out to cato want some boots so
there is a man here in california who
was having some issues in his marriage
and he decided to go
to a
psychic which this woman was texting
with him for a while telling him oh
if you come in for a tarot card reading
i can tell you what's happening in your
relationship he goes and this woman
tells him that he has a curse put upon
him by his ex-girlfriend and the only
way she can lift it if is if he does
this
uh i don't know what she calls exactly
but she's charging him fifty four
hundred dollars for to lift this curse
essentially and he puts down a down
payment of a grand
a few weeks later he realizes nothing
happens nothing changes in his marriage
he goes to complain to her and she
refuses to give the money back so now he
is suing her for 25 000 dollars in
damages now the judge is gonna go that's
on you my man that's on you sir that's
the news she's a believer
basically they're all liars
criminals i mean come on oh 5100 you're
a criminal they would be balling if
you're a criminal and a scumbag yeah
they're usually pretty general too she
describes her work as a phd life coach
hell yeah of course you do
you're a scumbag and you're a liar but
also if you're dumb enough to fall for
that you deserve to lose your money i
agree they both it's a good economy let
them both do it actually
everybody is it's all good i would never
do anything let it all happen let let
the dummies lose their money let the
scam artists make money [ __ ] it if
you're that dumb that's crazy i agree
you're gonna lift a curse cool
so the next one just the fact that he
thought it was a curse is a problem
that's right
that's right
that's something uh my family used to
believe in too uh my uncle thought that
his ex-wife had put a curse on him
because she got a tattoo of his face on
her butt love it and he actually paid a
sidekick i think it was ten thousand
dollars to remove the curse because he
was having uh terrible luck in his love
life he says everything's fine now but
yeah
he has her face on his ass uh yes she
got his ex-girlfriend
he's a flat ass it was probably a flat
ass honestly he likes them the porch is
probably [ __ ] money
you know what i'm saying because it's a
flat surface
i don't know how well she cast a spell
on somebody and the next day or the week
later yeah that woman all her teeth fell
out so so maybe there's something to it
that might be something that that's when
you know that the curse is real if you
can be like
that now
say it and the teeth fell out
oh my god
i would pay 10 grand be like hey reverse
oh i'll go right now you might yeah or i
would just go buy some chompers like
jokes on you i got veneers [ __ ]
i got better people yeah you have better
teeth [ __ ] you
i'm gonna play five yards
the [ __ ] zodiac killer is still doing
it huh so a team of specialists
have been working on the zodiac killer
cold case and they believe they have the
zodiac killer
identity and they believe it's this man
his name is gary f post or postie he was
uh
in the bay area during those attacks and
he actually passed away in 2018 but a
lot of the scars that he has on his arms
match with the records of the attacks
and a lot of the um clues and the
riddles that he left matches up with his
name oh interesting so they believe this
is him and not the guy that they made
the zodiac killer movie really yeah
yeah really yeah so this is the guy they
believe this is the guy
wow i'm not weird he got away with it
that [ __ ] long and then [ __ ] with
the san francisco
pd with like write letters and [ __ ] it's
nuts and you know they still can't
figure out and decipher his writing
they've tried for years a team
barely they can get certain words they
can't get all of it it's weird right
it's very weird he was a former hold on
other clues include the suffering letter
sent by the zodiac that revealed him as
a killer said okay
wow
yeah he's a psychopath uh yeah just got
off on not only killing but he would
write letters to the
surviving the victim's families how nuts
is that how nuts is it he's sadist how
many serial killers just get away
well i mean the golden state killer
basically got it they're like we caught
him he's 80. he got away with it
this guy jesus christ
damn great movie though zodiac killer
good movie
i feel bad for
i know
did you ever see the uh documentary i
think it was on fx the zag killer and
this guy is like my dad oh yes dude he
has daddy issues and he's convinced that
his dad
are lit as [ __ ] this guy's like my dad's
zodiac killer and he goes to san
francisco meets with the victims meets
with forensic meets with the police
department and i'm like holy [ __ ] and
i'm like why isn't there more news if
this guy's death is oh yeah kill that's
a big deal
episode 5 they interview his mom
and she's like no all right sex with
zoey and i've been waiting she's like i
know at my time she's like i know he's
dead his dad dad's in cleveland you're
all what and she's like yeah i don't
know why he's doing this y'all [ __ ] dude
you made up a bunch of different but why
would f
yeah why would fx do that so annoying
and then you'd be like look at this you
can't tell me this drawing is not my dad
you're like that's the first episode
you're like [ __ ] they look pretty
similar well when you look back on it
yeah they both had glasses i guess have
you seen vendetta
yeah that about the journalist yeah
in italy oh it's a documentary yeah no
oh i'm talking i thought you talked
about the movie no
no bring a vendetta truth lies in the
mafia
look at this
bring up the trailer for this you you
this is new yeah i think you'd probably
be into this
you have two options
one the guy looks like the monopoly guy
also
[Music]
i don't know why they have there's seven
people talking
no go go back and put it put on just
show show uh that's gonna be tough yeah
show the actual trailer because it's
that's the trailer dude this is the
that's actually really because the one i
saw he gives the gist of it
that was terrible this dude right here
just goes he he goes i'm gonna expose
what country and what country sicily oh
wow and he's like and he goes you're
pieces of [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] i
can't believe he's still alive well they
hung his dogs
they hung his dogs okay and then yeah
but now they then they they the way the
mafia fights you because then they have
a judge
the judge judge
they started seeing there you go here
you go
here you go and this is the same one
same one with subtitles
[Music]
[Music]
she's the biggest
oh he's a character oh yeah
[Music]
about fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the mafia took the so you've got a
journalist who's trying to expose them
and then you have the number one judge
who's seizing all their assets oh
interesting and suddenly all of a sudden
they they're like let's start [ __ ]
these guys were working for the mafia
mafia doesn't [ __ ] around they'll
they'll they'll create these things and
all of a sudden you're like wait what's
really going on
that's so good that guy looks insane but
oh yeah
gutsy [ __ ] though you'd have to
be you'd have to be he went to the boss
of boss's town in sicily where the
bosses of the bosses are so he has been
working with him he's like these guys
are scumbags they're going to kill him
easily he had to been working with well
the thing is they also you know i mean
his his network he's got his network his
little network is in a [ __ ] apartment
building dude this should be called
vendetta we both ugly
well yeah they smoke
they do a lot of smoking look at those
[ __ ] look at that mustache
he looks ridiculous
what else you got
okay so there is a new tick tock trend
that people are calling out uh i forgot
what exactly was called but the gist of
it is that you kind of
devious licks thank you uh where a bunch
of students are just doing devious
things it started out with uh a picture
of kids basically tearing down a
restroom in a school they tear down the
stalls the st the sink out of the wall
and it's actually graduated to the point
where people are now slapping teachers
no [ __ ] way yeah because if my kid
slapped a teacher
oh my god slapping teachers and there's
video of them slapping teachers uh yes
there is but the platform is actually
taking it down they're trying to erase
that whole hashtag so people can't like
tick-tock you stop all this [ __ ] so
kids you know because obviously they
just want likes and views and clicks so
if you take that down they're not going
to do it that's right what are you doing
tick-tock
so the connecticut attorney general
actually came out with a statement
saying that tick tock is failing to
spread uh stop the spread of this
dangerous content because it's
escalating you were just trying to do
bigger and bigger owned by china yeah i
believe so yes
suspect but how do they not just flag
this off the bat like all right we can't
have this dude slapping a t you imagine
slapping your teacher as a kid i was so
terrified of my teachers i've seen my
teacher in a [ __ ] at the grocery
store and it was like life would be over
yeah but oh my god tent's up even though
i didn't do anything your life would be
obvious wasn't it weird when you saw
your teacher at the grocery store like
holy [ __ ] they do something besides
teach and they're out side clothes
that's like they don't eat food yeah i
had a kid nine year old tell me to [ __ ]
off hell yeah
[ __ ] off hell yeah i was like is this
court taking cause you're just throwing
a ball into that dog i want to play
tennis yeah i love that yeah we're
playing here [ __ ] off i love that and i
went whoa whoa whoa young man that's all
i could do his mom was like jeremiah i
was like [ __ ] off jesus christ man
full throated [ __ ] off
yeah that's not the first time you said
it hurt my feelings yeah actually hurt
my feelings what are you going to do
yeah i was also like [ __ ] this these are
just keep them busy though and it was a
big nine-year-old okay keem busy yeah
the nine-year-old
let's go bro hey what's going on
let's go say it to my face he's like i
said i'll do to you what shop does to me
when we wrestle
yo you don't know who he is what else
yet
so this one's a sad one i think we've
talked about this selfie before it went
viral where two gorillas were taking a
photo with their caretaker one of the
gorillas actually recently passed away
in the arms of her caretaker damn from
what uh illness it i don't think it says
exactly what it was but she had an
illness that finally just kind of took
her
dude is she older yeah she was an older
one
i was when i was in uh indonesia and i
worked with she was 14.
she was 14. that's still young for an
eight maybe is it i think so they lived
like 30 40. when i was in uh
this guy took he would uh rehabilitate
the orphans and one of the babies died
they couldn't get that guy out of bed
that was his daughter they couldn't get
him out of bed holy [ __ ] those [ __ ]
things you get so attached to those
young you have no idea chimps live
[ __ ] 39 apes lived 39 years oh yeah
dude
that's a human to you man believe me if
you don't you don't want to chimp and
you don't want it to die it'll destroy
you
if it's your friend if it's your pet
you it's it's a human dude there's some
chimp that lived at 88 for god's sakes
they're they're um the expression in
their eyes i know this from working with
orangutans they're there
no but they're human dude no they're
like our closest thing to us right and
you don't say working with them but they
have emotions i know but don't say
working with the running team you didn't
work when i was working with them when i
was rehabilitating them okay i was there
at first i saw them no i actually you
passed it i helped yeah i helped you
pass the water i gave mangoes don't say
working with orangutan i gave pineapple
that's triggering for me
and they like pineapples they love
pineapple when i was working to
rehabilitate them into the wild
for two weeks with earthwatch when i was
21
um
boring [ __ ] boring after a while but
um yeah but didn't you and your sister
do it yeah and they get but they throw
tantrums they they get super attached to
you and which aren't you hitting on the
lady who's like balls deep in orange
tank you're hitting on her and your
sister was like scientist and when
you're just like now he lives with me
she was scientist i said other than she
said i live in d.c you should come visit
me she was like 28 and i was so
underwear and my my sister goes um
he uh he doesn't he lives in dc but that
means he goes to college and he lives in
another apartment at my dad pays for my
dad pays for everything and he calls he
goes and he calls and asks for money all
the time what's wrong with her [ __ ]
grenade
grenading me at every turn hater she
would grenade me at every turn yeah he
doesn't pay for anything he's never had
a job my dad pays for everything he's
rich i like hate he builds killing me at
21 i want to be a my sister is a
non-bullshit
dude we're just [ __ ] taking it
i saw her the other day i saw her friend
i dropped tiger off and her friend was
like oh you're the you do the show with
brian i go yeah she goes i'm really
close with his sister
yeah and that was it that's it yep i
went cool there it is see you on the
other side nobody know what that nobody
could take my wheels off better than my
sister hey what's that mean see on the
other side like when we pass away i i
even tiger was like what yeah i was like
i said cool see you on the other side
and then she just pulls out a gun and
kills herself yeah
we're both on the same side that's
pretty wild that's something you say
when we're going to go to battle right
we're going in we're going to charge
that hill we have we have it's squid
games and i go hey see on the side see
any other side brother and i panicked we
got panicked you know when you get out
of conversation i'm like yeah that's
cool see on the other side and like ah i
used to feel that way when you would be
when you were fighting and you would go
train and i would get dead serious and i
would look at you remember i felt like
this i don't know why but it was i was
dead serious and i go like this i'd go
hey
train well huh
all right go good training okay like i
say it loud and you go like this yes sir
and you disappear i don't know i just
felt like we were i feel like
whatever city you're in and you're
eating dinner and the the waitress or
waiter go hey good luck tonight you too
man
he's like yeah i'm good dude i'm [ __ ]
but if you perform i'm dishing out
orange chicken you perform yeah thanks
for the luck yeah that's like that's
like tonight youtube ryan regan does
that too it's called like when you get
out of the taxi have a good flight you
too
you too
when you fly too you at the times that
you fly you too have a good fight too
it's so awkward it's so true though it's
just natural like you too man do it all
the time i did this to
i did this to the guy who is doing mold
in my house
and i don't know why i got along talking
to him was great and i just i'm so used
to this i go
i'll see you later i love you bro
i go
and that's not what i meant and that's
what i say sometimes i don't know why i
said that it was so [ __ ] awkward
he looked at me like
just like a white dude kind of a big
white dude like handsy like blue color
he was the cable i love you man i love
you bro we've been talking politics and
i i love you man ah no i love saying i
love you bro to guys who aren't
comfortable with you that's the best
have a good day dude dad's accountant
did that to him my dad's a cat i love
you love you my dad goes
yeah
i
yeah is my fly open you know my dad's
old school might fly open oh it's not
you love me love me he just like walked
away oh my god don't do that to him
what don't you guys get so this is the
last story i have today uh twitch the
streaming site actually got hacked
recently and somehow they posted a list
of their top earners from october 2019
to august 2021
and number one they uh this channel made
9.6 million dollars this does not
include merch or youtube views this is
strictly on twitch with their
sponsorships donations from fans and
nick merks my twin can we start doing
nick
my twin made 5 mil he signed exclusively
with twitch as well man yeah a lot of
these people are uh twitch partners so
they exclusively stream on this platform
the number one channel is actually a
dungeons and dragons channel so you just
watch people play dungeons and dragons
for hours how much does that channel
make uh apparently 9.6 million and that
doesn't count youtube or merch it's just
on this platform we can we twitch uh if
i can pan yeah yep yep we have the
capability to do that yeah we did yeah
we did last time right
i still i i have no i've never been on
twitch so it's like
that's nuts
oh sick
big boy live on twitch wow
wow
okay interesting huh yes
this is what yeah what would you say i
was gonna say that's what eric griffin
is talking about when he says he made a
lot of money on uh streaming i don't see
his name in the top 25 not on the top 25
but if he's making a living if he can
make a living off of it he's living
there how's which work do they run ads
while you're doing it
how you get paid or is it off
subscribers so uh to my knowledge there
are subscribers and then there are uh
donations that subscribers can give and
on top of that you also have
sponsorships in between you streaming
and cat is only fans that you're just
paid solely off subscribers there's no
subscribers and then people
and what's up yeah and then tips what's
pay-per-view pay-per-view is like any
extra content i want to sell so if i
have like a the other day i went to go
get a pedicure and i would sell extra
photos of my feet for your feet yeah
dude and you can only get those photos
if you pay the pay-per-view price yes if
i send you the dm with the option so um
how much is something like that
it depends i've never been on only fans
so like i've never have either but i'd
like to get out what would i do could i
make money how much would i make if i
zero dollars if i if i was just like
here it is oh you're a big dick yeah
it's not a bad idea but the doing things
like my dick running balancing yeah yeah
you know what i mean like your balls
from behind yeah my bulldog or brian
bulldogging bulldogging we got flapping
yep we got helicopter horse or brian yep
we got we got it super cold i make it
cold i i i put some ice on it and we see
it all kind of you know you have people
vote how cold should i go today oh like
negative 40. i'm getting some cold water
i just dip just my three-piece set in
cold water it's like a magical you put
your dick in like a snow cone oh and it
comes out all kinds of points and then
the fans can vote what flavor ice cream
oh it's chocolate chip and your dick's a
sandwich between chocolate well i just
drag it i drag my three-piece set across
a tub of ice cream oh that'd be fun and
people bought an ice cream yeah dude i
bet you make some good are there a lot
of guys yeah yeah they're uh some of the
toppers are guys
maybe they're not gonna they're doing
for me though dude i guarantee you'll
make i bet there's a niche for you i bet
there is you start posting that big
heavy gray route yeah i bet you make
20 20 grand a month really
but you but you got to get creative with
that dick
i could dress it up put little hats on
oh dude my mom comes to the green room
and she goes hey i heard how much cat's
making she goes i think about starting
the only fan she doesn't have a job
yeah my mom j that's issues i think i
started only fans it's in front of all
my friends i go do this later mom she
goes no seriously she's like like all
you got to do is like talk to some old
guy and like talk sexy you don't might
go please stop that she goes that's
traumatic dude she goes out she goes i
mean i just got to talk about like
cradling his nuts in my mouth or
something like that mom please i beg you
[ __ ] stop please stop and i go no
you know it's not sexting though you
gotta like show girls pictures she goes
i don't want to do that
well
dear god stop
okay
and you're next to it going like this
i'm not doing it i can't no but your
faces are like this pointing at it
or me like this yeah little things like
that or me hyping up like hey today's
[ __ ] rocky road wow let's see brian's
dick navigate through rocky road
and then you just spike your dick in the
rice i'm not hot enough i bet you oh i
disagreed dude i think you'd make bank
yeah
and only fans i am baking bread now i
made bread yesterday it could be brian
bacon bread
look i bait i'm spelt and buttermilk oh
i made some good [ __ ] bread butter on
that it's already been done tom papa's
doing that dude really yeah
dude the dick and ice cream is our move
you think so yeah and we drive we do
like yeah
casey take it easy you look like you're
you look like you just ate something
that was tasty
his face is like dude when we dress it
up we like halloween oh it's a ghost oh
you're just in the sheets with a rock
hard boner it's a ghost and then for
things we draw eyes on it's giving he
looks like a turkey
oh look at this big turkey neck against
your nuts yep that'd be sick it's a
pretty oh it's santa claus it's rudolph
the red nosed car
pets i have a bunch of costumes for
butters that i can pass down to you
afterwards oh my god dude this is
brilliant like i got him a little hot
dog suit for uh halloween dude or i
paint your dick for you and it's like oh
is it an anaconda or brian's dick pain
and people we keep them on their toes
finger painting and you're like this
with your giant fingers dang dang please
yeah please i'll pleasure i'll do it
that's my sound effect for brennan
finger painting
we do it around movies like dude there's
so much [ __ ] we could do like like the
new batman comes out and then we paint
your dick all black with little white
eyes it's just thematic for everything
and then there's like spider-man oh he's
shooting bro
hey check it out shooting rope
spider-man
spider-man shooting ropes
oh he's spinning webs everybody uh-huh
now are people gonna throw up or are
they gonna pay for it probably throw up
and that's the end of me
i don't think so we pay my dick orange
donald trump it's donald trump week
hilarious right with a little orange wig
on him huh and he's going like this
oh that'd be fun yep oh just the just
the peepee mouth
[Music]
oh i've always said
beautiful people don't yeah that'd be
great they're rushing the capitol mr
president do something
don't yeah
we can do that
mr president january 6th they're
charging they're in nancy pelosi's
office go home dude we do a biden one we
do a buying one and you're you're
shaking your dick
i'm casper the angry ghost i know it's
stuttering it's all he he
is somebody did my makeup with chalk
yeah
dude i like this idea i've seen more
color in their face than vampires dude i
like this idea that's a good idea dude
that's a really good idea
it's a good month to start it's october
halloween themed and then we have puppet
dick where my dick is attached to
strings when i'm
my nuts are going this way my dick's
going that way
and i'm like oh that stings we make your
nuts twerk
just you're not behind me
yeah just your nuts or twerking not your
ass
that could be a trend let's make some
money
twerking nuts from the back and not no
no we can do that dude look guys the
important thing is i'm gonna be in
columbus this weekend friday saturday
and then i'll be i'll be in columbus and
then get ready i'm in mcgooby's [ __ ]
magoobs
maryland can they change the club
timonium maryland mcgoobies i'm there
get your tickets at briancallen.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com
october 14th 15th 16th timonium then i'm
in liberty township ohio october 22nd
23rd that's
the 30th i think i'm going to be here
bubba cowbest fight companion we can do
the fight companion
we also have one november 6th don't we
we have a double feature canelo caleb
that's a ban ufc 260. that's a big one
big boy
so we might have to do the fight
companion i'm in vegas tonight man there
will be no dick magic like brian but
it's a fun show vegas tonight wise guys
thursday friday saturday vegas your boy
is in town and then next week brea
california is thurs sorry friday and
saturday only break california then
dallas texas
taping the special peppa baby 30 minutes
special come in [ __ ] hot november
11th through the 13th dallas texas
addison improv tickets are on sale right
now says chicago
but to cancel that date so we can do a
calabash fight campaign for the big ufc
great grand wonderful love you guys
thanks for the support vegas see tonight
brian keep that dick heavy you will
buddy i love it love you guys good time
thanks fellas